هجوم عابر للحدود على اوكرانيا انطلاقا من
بيلاروسيا هو احتمال لم يعد مستبعدا ابدا
في ظل التطورات الحاليه وايضا تقدم الجيش
الاوكراني على الارض كيف عبر وزاره الدفاع
يتوقعت اي يشهد شهر فبراير محاوله غزو
روسيه جديده للاراضي الاوكرانيه لم تستبعد
ان تكون الاراضي البيلاروسيا نقطه انطلاق
هذه الحمله احتمال سبقتها في الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه ايضا والتي حذرت من ان التهديد
بغزو شمالي ثامن طبعا بالرغم من انه منخفض
الا انه يبقى ممكنا وغير مستبعدا خصوصا
لتخفيف الضغط عن الجبهات في الشرق وايضا
في الجنوب احتمالات اشار اليها لا بل وحذر
منها الامين العام لحلفي الناتو قائلا ان
الدلاله لا تشير الى ان موسكو تستعد لشنه
هجوم برج جديد واسع نطاق داعيا اوكرانيا
الى الاستعداد لصراعا طويله
[موسيقى]